first of all okay so I want to start
with um I was shocked to hear that you
guys pulled this thing off in like 38
days as a shoot that's crazy
you two get terrible a sign that you
managed to pull this thing off
did you ever feel the pressure cuz
people don't realize a lot of the big
big movies take like 90 days or a
hundred days yeah 38 s not a lot no it's
not no I think you know I think with the
good fortune of Andrea burlap as our
writer and director and I do think
there's I think there's something to
when the the person directing is also
your writer because they they know it
backwards and forwards they know where
they want to go how far they want to
take it and there's no kind of
interpretation extra time that's needed
so maybe that makes it this much more
possible
I think we're surprised too because it
just didn't feel rushed it didn't feel
like it was I didn't it didn't feel like
it was that short it felt like we had
the time to do what we needed to do on
it okay sure I have what we call a few
questions
No we'll see yeah we'll be the judges of
that who was the fastest at leaving
their trailer Oh Melissa's always the
fastest of getting anywhere I'm a nerd I
grew up on a farm so I always had to
leave so early to get on time yeah still
like I I can't shake it yeah who ruined
the most takes very question to answer
who ruined them who messed up
you know like basically - she's never
it's not hurt in any world yes not her
it's definitely Tiffany or myself
she's very irritating Lee I'm like does
it ever gonna be could it be bad once if
it's just to kind of for morale building
could you do one terrible take it answer
isn't it's very nice of you think I
think I know what the next answer is who
always gets it in one I mean this this
one in margo martindale
oh yeah first yeah she's the worst worst
terrible woman terrible
a terrible actor too I mean awful don't
buy it Margo do you have a favorite ride
at Disneyland
probably Thunder Mountain does I think
it hits it hits both the roller-coaster
and the fantasy idea and it's not too
scary it doesn't make you too nauseous
but gives you like a little bit of a
thrill I'm a kind of a teacup gal oh I'm
not really I don't
I want anything to shake me mmm just go
swirl yeah like a swirl and I love
coffee so what is the secret to a great
relationship with your cinematographer I
would say acknowledge yeah being
educated about what they're doing and
they're being them being educated about
what you are doing and if you guys can
both get on the same page it definitely
makes for the most symbiotic
relationship do you remember your first
movie or TV show crush I was real sweet
on Wonder Woman am I almost like you're
watching that with an intense iam I am
then I also love the hulk lou
and okay bill bixby
both I was torn so I don't know I mean
there was a real range going for me I
was I wasn't quite sure which way the
chip I had one and then I forgot oh yeah
Gene Kelly oh yeah I loved musicals as a
kid and and Gene Kelly O's you know I
mean I was the dancing sure my last
thing for you um what TV show would you
love to guest star on and it can't be
what she's currently on or what you guys
you know yeah yeah yeah I had a
monologue prepared but it's currently
airing or it doesn't matter of all time
Jesus Christ
the leftovers for me I would have loved
to have been a fly on the wall anywhere
in that show I have so many questions so
many questions yeah
um there's one weird weird world where
I'd love to say CSI because I would like
to also walk it to room with Caruso and
take my glasses off yeah which is always
kind of a biggie for me I would love to
just for no reason be like who's that
lady so that's that's one spectrum and
then well if I can't do anything of hers
I don't know I don't know maybe maybe
I'll leave it at that Kurt's Caruso
Russo Crusoe all the way that was the
curveball Congrats on the movie thank
you for adultery other questions